>>Narrator: It's the
dream of every educator.
Here at C. P. Squires Elementary,
children are so eager to learn,
they burst through the
schoolyard gates every morning.
>>Teacher: Hey, boys and girls,
today, while you're eating,
we're going to read this story, "The
Berenstain Bears Christmas Tree."
>>Narrator: Before the
school day even begins,
they are treated to bagels and books.
>>Teacher: What do you think
the Berenstain Bears are going
to do with a Christmas tree?
>>Narrator: Since 90 percent
of Squires incoming students
don't speak a word of English,
literacy is the school's
primary focus.
>>Carol: The only hope our
Hispanic youngsters have, I believe,
is to master English, and then
they will truly be bilingual.
I say to the parents, it's your
responsibility to teach them Spanish
in your home, and please do
that, and it's our responsibility
to teach them English, and then
they will have all their world open
to them.
And so I really believe that poverty
and second language are
absolutely not any excuse
for not teaching children to read.
>>Teacher: A, B, Cs,
and counting, one--
>>Narrator: Teachers here use a
variety of techniques to teach
and reinforce English
language skills,
from memorizing months
with the Macarena..
>>All: May, June, July,
August, September--
>>Narrator: To learning
letters with a talking mat.
>>Teacher: C. What sound does C make?
>>Carol: What I guaranteed
each teacher was
that if they would just
slow down their speech,
and tech everything
three different ways,
that these little five
year olds are like sponges,
and they will pick it up.
And the brain research
supports that dramatically.
The first year it was very
scary, because we weren't sure.
Now we're positive.
We know that it works, and
when they go into first grade,
we have 98 percent mastery
of all letters and sounds.
[Singing]
>>Narrator: Technology plays a key
role in advancing reading skills.
>>Tracey: I have 30-some
students, and it's hard to sit
down with one child every day.
They go on the computer
every day for 15 minutes,
and it's just individualized
for them.
>>Computer: Find the balloon, T.
>>Tracey: They learn to write their
names, they learn the A, B, Cs,
and then they focus on
each letter individually.
And then they advance when they know
that letter, they test themselves.
>>Student: The truck had to squeeze
to stop to avoid running over Sammy.
>>Narrator: Students also
get individual attention
from older students, who act
as their reading buddies.
And from volunteer mentors
like Thomas Washington.
>>Thomas: Tell me that sound.
What is that sound?
>>Student: C-- C--
>>Thomas: Very good.
>>I was in the third grade, before I
really learned how to decode and how
to read, and read successfully.
So I feel that I have to share
it, because I had a strong person
that helped me when I was in school.
>>Thomas: Well, what is 14 times 5?
Now you can use the pen if you want,
but I want you to use your head.
This is called mental math.
>>The more smart kids we have,
the better our future will be.
The more kids that are able to
take care of themselves and provide
for themselves, the
better we're going to be.
>>Student: Twenty-five.
>>Thomas: Right.
>>Tracey: Oh, you've got a big book.
>>Narrator: The school has
received several grants,
and partnered with local business
to start innovative programs
like this monthly book giveaway.
>>Tracey: What did you pick?
Baby Animals.
>>A lot of these children don't
have many books in the homes.
>>There you go, that's
yours to keep forever.
>>They have several children at
home, parents don't have much money
to go buy books, so this lets them
have books that are theirs to keep
at home, to read with little
brothers and sisters, and uncles
and aunts, and mom and dad.
>>Doctor: Here, put
this under your tongue.
>>Narrator: A new medical clinic
at C. P. Squires also serves three
other schools in the neighborhood.
>>Carol: Now we have a
health center on our campus.
We can take care of dental,
vision, any kind of problem,
any kind of cold, flu, whatever.
>>Doctor: Do you wear your seatbelt?
>>Parent: I would, but
we don't have a car.
>>Doctor: Oh.
Okay.
>>Carol: I like to think of it
as a one stop community
center, and it should be.
The hub of society, I
think should be the school.
>>Narrator: Lark is addressing
the needs of all family members
in the community with an array
of after school programs centered
around preschool literacy.
>>All: Green, blue, orange, red.
>>Carol: As soon as the
kindergarteners go home
in the afternoon, I have three
groups of four year olds that come
into those classrooms, and we start
doing basically the same program
that we do during the day, with
the guidance of a licensed teacher.
>>All: A star!
>>Teacher: Number one,
John is a student.
>>All: John is a student.
>>Teacher: He isn't a teacher.
>>Carol: We knew we had to meet
the needs of the entire family,
so by working with the middle school
across the street, the parents go
across the street and get
English lessons, which is going
to enhance their future
in terms of job potential
and all the older siblings,
they have many choices.
Like, right now, we have intramural
soccer going on, we have ballet--
>>Teacher: Seven, and-- one,
two, three, four, five, six--
>>Carol: And we have line dancing.
>>Leah: The biggest thing,
building self esteem.
They didn't think they'd
be able to perform.
First of all, they couldn't
even do the first dance.
They said, we can't do this.
Now they know three dances, we're
working on, The Cowboy Hip Hop.
I told the girls they can't dance
in sneakers, because you don't look
like a cowgirl if you're
dancing in sneakers.
So a lot of them have not had
the means to get cowboy boots,
so I have six pairs, and I lend
them out and they wear big socks,
and a couple of them I bought myself,
and hopefully Santa Claus
will bring them boots.
>>Carol: These teachers
are caring teachers.
I hire for heart first.
I can train, I can teach anything.
But you have to hire for people
who thrive on that feeling.
It feels so good when
children succeed.
You saw their faces.
They're happy and they're
growing and they're learning.
I mean, it doesn't get
any better than that.
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.